the team behind wildlife you guys have
known each other for a while you and
jake gyllenhaal did a movie in 2009
called brothers you and Zoe Kazan around
the same time we're on the stage in New
York together in the seagull Zoe and
paul dano of course are a couple in real
life were you all talking about doing
something together for a long time were
you talking about doing this
specifically for a long time
definitely something together Zoe and I
shared a dressing room when we did the
see girls she played Marshall I played
Nina exactly ten years ago and she has
written a lot she's written lots of play
she wrote Ruby sparks she's experienced
screenwriter so I was always bugging her
write something that we could do
together but ideally for us to act
together and then Jake and I have known
each other forever and I had about two
minutes and a Jim Sheridan film brothers
that Jake was in and we had read plays
together and talked about doing theater
together and that never worked out and I
always wanted to work with Paul but
never told him to his face so yeah we
hadn't discussed this and actually
they'd worked on it for years but it
kind of came out the blue for me I
didn't know and Paul called me up on a
Friday night said I'm gonna send you a
script and just read ins who you think I
was curious to hear your reaction to the
plot of the film and the arc of
Jeannette and I was curious if he had
explained it to you or if you read about
it first in the either the novel or the
script what was your first reaction yeah
no he didn't he gave no kind of context
at all yes head check your email so I
read it and had a completely fresh
perspective and hadn't read the book
either so I mean the first thing that
really struck me was that sort of a
nostalgic whiplash that she's
experiencing of sort of you know the
moment where you hear a song on the
radio and realize that you cried about
your boyfriend dumping you to that song
but you know 10 years before and
suddenly kind of have that feeling of
where as time gone you know and I think
that what is what Jeanette is
experiencing in a really negative way
and then you know there were so many
interesting conversations with Paul and
Zoey but the amazing thing about the
script that I read was that it barely
changed to what we short
I mean if at all and I think that was
just down to the years of aid spent
working on it and
you know the really they had fought
through every single piece of Jeanette's
journey the 1960 timeframe adds so much
to the movie as far as the look in the
feel and the language and the music I've
totally downloaded now maybe by the
shantel's
just to saw that you're playing in the
car I just love it so much what did you
find most interesting about this
character in this time period and maybe
family dynamics in general in 1960 yeah
I think you know just the incredibly
heavy weight on the mother's shoulders
on the wife shoulders I think part of
what happens to Jeanette is a buildup of
pressure and I think it starts when she
meets Jerry I think they have a really
lovely romance I think it's all real I
think they the start of their
relationship is great but there is a
contract between them kind of unspoken
contract that as long as he keeps up his
side of the deal which is he will get a
job and if he lose this one he will get
another one and he will be an all-around
good guy and be a nice guy and she will
keep up her side which is being great
mom and a great wife and wearing the
apron and doing the meals and making
good of a very little income and every
time they are forced to move house
making the best of it but I think it's
only when hearin aches on his side of
the deal that that all falls apart and
because of the time period she has no
higher education no discernible skills
no way of making a living for herself so
the crisis that she's in is that much
more terrifying to see Jeanette the
change in Jeanette after Jerry leaves is
fascinating what kind of stuff happened
from a filmmaking point of view to mark
that difference as far as the costuming
maybe the way Paul decided to shoot you
and of course in the performance how did
you delineate before and after yeah so
that was kind of the most fun bit was
figuring all of that out and the
complicated thing about that was that
the first very first scene that I shot
was the scene in the diner which is
exactly smack BAM in the middle of that
week so it's that was the probably the
hardest thing to shoot because I just
had no idea if I was doing the right
thing and I remember even texting Zoey
the next day knowing that she would have
seen the rushes in New York and saying
like I think I just messed that I've
idea what that was you know I'm hoping
for the best but who knows but actually
a lot of that was costume and and
speaking with the man to fooled because
I saw that week and her life as a sort
of identity crisis as I said you know
that this every the role that she's
played for the last 14 years is perfect
mother and perfect wife and trying to do
and say the right thing all the time and
when that veneer goes away she kind of
doesn't know who she is if she's anyone
at all so I think she's reaching into
the back catalogs to try and find you
know the version of herself that she
could have been had her life gone
differently so I could have been a shoot
Beauty I could have been I could have
been married to a millionaire I could
have I could have been a poet and lived
in France you know all of these versions
of herself that were possible and so we
kind of explored those through the
costume and the makeup and that was
really fun i think paul dano did such a
fantastic job I mean you guys all
remember him playing Brian Wilson and
love and mercy a couple of years ago but
now he's proven himself such a great
filmmaker
what are your embraces and impressions
of him as far as his demeanor as a
director I just completely assured and
calm and I'm wonderful I mean I kind of
knew instantly that he was gonna do a
really good job I think you just have to
see his work as an actor and novi he
hasn't whatever genre of film he's in
he's always really truthful and I think
I kind of if that's all I'm really
interested in doing I just want to play
a real person tell a true story and I
think I knew that Paul would do that
without fail and he did and being on set
you know he had such a clear vision of
what he wanted to do and he was so good
at communicating it to everyone and I
think above and beyond that it just
helps that he's a really wonderful human
being he's just such a nice man and
people loved him and they wanted to do a
really good job for him and they
believed in him because he's so talented
so he created a set where everyone came
into their best work and then most
particularly with me I think you know he
made it okay to just do really terrible
work you know and that was really
freeing and really helpful so the scene
that was probably one of the most
complicated was the scene at Warren
Miller's house where she's wearing the
green dress and and she comes into it
with an eye
dear of how to behave and that changes
and she's constantly having to change
her strategy and she thinks that she's
aligned with Warren Miller but she's not
and it just every to beat she's having
to soar and she's getting more drunk and
Paul was so great cuz he literally said
like just do a terrible take just do the
worst thing you can imagine just act so
badly and I won't let it be bad in the
film like I'll make sure that but it was
just a way of kind of letting helping me
kind of relax and let go you mentioned
the fact that you were making this at
the time where you had a one-year-old I
think you might have even been pregnant
with your son while you were making this
or right around there or something do
you feel like being a mom allowed you to
put your best foot forward in this kind
of a role or would it not have mattered
could you have done this five years ago
before being a mom I don't know if I
could have done it five years ago I mean
that I hopefully try him try to get
better as I go along so hopefully I
wouldn't have figured it out maybe you
know I just hopefully I'm sort of
learning as I go along getting better I
think there are some things that are
different now that I have kids I mean
certainly my criteria for working has
changed the bar has been set so high by
wildlife and by girls and boys and the
quality of the writing means that it
would just feel like a cheat to do
anything that was sort of easier and
less interesting than that because I
wouldn't want to spend the time away
from my kids but it's work you know it I
weigh it up and I know that I would kick
myself if I didn't do jobs I wildlife
girls and boys and there are some things
that that just changed I think you know
there was a scene in the film where Joe
comes home right towards the end and and
he says there's everything you know what
do you know what's gonna happen to us
and I think Jerry just looks at the
floor and Janette says I don't know and
I hadn't I guess given a huge amount of
thought maybe we hadn't reversed it was
something but in the moment of shooting
it just suddenly struck me as completely
tragic to know that I will not always be
able to reassure my children and they
are one three years old right now so I
can pick them up and put a plaster on
their knee and and tell them that
they'll be alright but the idea that one
day I won't be able to do that and all
that even worse that I'll actually
actively fail them just
so suddenly terrifying Carey Mulligan
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
it's great to see you